[Music]
in the cold white north of minnesota
there's a place that will get you warm
after a long day on the ice
you can do some fishing
or have a tasty beverage
and it's something of a dream for josie
i've always wanted to own a neighborhood
bar and we finally do mine's just
sitting on a frozen lake
ice fishing is a way of life around here
for people
it gets so cold below zero attempts
quite often which allows us to drive and
put houses out and drill holes in the
lake and fish
when it gets cold enough in the early
winter
josie's husband goes out and tests the
ice to make sure it's thick enough
[Music]
if it is they can put the bar together
and then the ice hole can open
the ice here is so thick that this bar
sits on top of it
to come to our bar on the lake you just
drive your car out on the ice and park
we don't have a parking lot you just
park wherever you want walk in and have
a beer
people like to fish and drink beer and
from our bar here you can do that all at
the same time
the local favorite drink here is called
the minnow shot people will actually
take a live minnow which is fishing bait
and put it into their shop and drink it
[Music]
oh yeah
as delicious as that seafood beverage
sounds people come just because the fact
that the bar exists is pretty amazing
people's reactions to this bar are from
crazy to they don't understand it that's
the coolest thing ever they come from
all over the world to see it it's very
seasonal we're only open 20 days
if you're ever near lake lida drive out
on the ice park come into the bar and
grab a pole
[Music]
water is just such an amazing medium
you can just see the crystals and how
they form in so many different ways and
then take that and extrapolate it to
these huge cliffs
what we do here is create spray ice and
probably make over 300 different climbs
[Music]
my name is alexander bianchi and i'm an
ice farmer we're down here in the
uncompacted gorge
we have a water system at the top of the
gorge
these galvanized steel shower heads
and it basically just sprays water out
over the cliffs and overnight when it's
cold it forms ice along the cliffs
what we really want is a nice clean
surface for the new water to come down
and just keep building off of that so a
lot of what we do here actually is repel
down a lot of these faces and just try
to clear that snow off ready for the
next layer
there's about two miles of ice if you
walk the bottom of the canyon and uh
yeah we farm ice all along the top of it
being an ice farmer is kind of hard work
we're gonna open up the south valve
sometimes i think we're no more than
like glorified plumbers
ice farming is art and engineering i
mean the two i think are always really
inseparable you know the engineering is
the logistics how do we get water from
point a to point b sometimes if the
valves aren't cracked quite enough you
get
a little bit of a freeze up the water
just doesn't get to the valve the remedy
is a blowtorch
artistic side is once we have this water
where we need it how can we do something
different how can we make something
interesting that you know we've never
climbed before it's definitely an
artistic process for some of us
i grew up rock climbing you know fair
weather climber first time i came out
here
was just kind of blown away it's so
different than rock climbing you're
climbing a transient medium the rock is
always going to be there this this ice
is not always there so it creates this
diversity and
this intense experience that i really
don't find in other facets of climate
and that's why i'm proud to do what i'm
doing
making drawings on land on quite a large
scale is something people can do for
thousands of years
[Music]
i'm simon beck
and i make drawings in the snow
[Music]
it started as a bit of fun
but gradually he's taken over my life
a ballpark estimate of footsteps
about 5 000 steps in an hour
a big drawing
two hours measuring eight hours work
you're looking at forty thousand steps
[Music]
i started doing it as an easy
alternative to hiking at the mountain
when i wanted an exercise
[Music]
you're starting with a drawer on a piece
of paper
or else to draw it in your mind
just treating it a bit like an
orienteering map
you're just going a certain distance in
a certain direction to determine
distances by counting bases
it's a very physical exercise it's
equivalent to a long days walking in the
hills when you make one of these big
drawings
[Music]
i'm just about the only person in the
world doing anything like it
[Music]
[Music]
this incredible colorful city
will only last a few months
but for one local designer the seasonal
spectacular is worth it
[Music]
jin zhang is an award-winning ice
sculptor and art teacher in harbin china
carbine is known as the city of ice and
each year hosts the incredible spectacle
the harbin snow and ice festival
these large scale designs are remarkable
but it's quite a process
one jinan knows well
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
starting with a block of plain ice may
seem daunting but to jin en this is just
the beginning
[Music]
of
foreign
but the reality of working with a
seasonal medium has its downfalls
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it's obviously an icon
for the mountain
just the symbol of it
[Music]
you don't have a lot of opportunity in
life these days
to have 10 or 12 minutes
[Music]
alone
[Music]
some people think
when they come here and they ride the
chair it's a lonely ride
i never really thought of it that way
mad river was founded by a guy named
roland palmetto because he wanted to
start a ski area where sport and not
money was going to be the overriding
concern he built the single chair here
in 1948
and then someone figured out very
quickly that a double chair was just as
easy to build as a single chair the
single chairs went away very quickly and
this thing has kind of hung around for a
long time
you're forced to really focus on what's
going on around you to look down just
watch some of the skiers having fun and
when you get up there you can look
across the valley into new york
[Music]
as the ski industry has changed over the
years this place hasn't everything that
we do
shouldn't work but it does
there's not a lot of ski areas in the
world where
the skiers are donating money to build a
lift
there's something about like you know
waiting in line in the corral and you're
going back and forth
and you're saying hi to people you're
carrying on multiple conversations
it's just a real friendly vibe
that you know it's not like a hashtag
campaign where we're trying to
create a community it's already here
sitting on that single chair
is like coming home
[Music]